what's going on guys this is rob and in
today's beyond
omega level video we're gonna be doing
things a little bit different because
instead of covering
one character we're gonna be talking
about an entire race of characters that
are basically some of the most powerful
beings in
all of the marvel universe the
celestials and i wanted to do this for a
couple reasons
one because all the celestials are
relatively the same in terms of power
level and i say that as a generalization
sure there are slight differences
between each of them but they're all
pretty similar enough that to understand
one of them is to basically understand
all of them secondly there really isn't
enough material
about one single celestial to merit its
own video so we're just gonna cover them
all here and i think it's important for
the series to have a video explaining
who the celestials are and what they're
capable of
because they aren't integral to the
history of the marvel universe so much
so
that a lot of the videos that we've made
over the years make reference to the
celestials when describing the feats of
powers of another character so if you
don't know much about them
it's hard to make sense of how
impressive those feats are so the
celestials were created by jack kirby
and made their first appearance in
eternals number two
in 1976 but their history within the
continuity of the marvel universe goes
back
billions of years and their origin was a
source of confusion for many readers for
several years
thankfully in recent years we've gotten
a little bit of clarity on how the
celestials came into being thanks to al
guling's ultimates 2 series in 2017
and their involvement in the marvel
studios eternals film but speaking of
marvel studios since they're owned by
disney
i figured it'd be an awesome time to
talk about disney heroes
battle mode now if you've never played
this disney heroes battle mode is a
free-to-play strategy based mobile
crossover rpg
where you can play with over 100 plus
disney and pixar heroes from big hero 6
to wreck it ralph
inside out and more the game centers
around digital city
where a wicked virus is corrupting every
pixel turning the hero's own
friends and family against them now i
grew up with all this stuff so jumping
into a game with a hundred plus
characters that i watched as a kid
was amazing and i personally loved
challenges so facing against enemies it
got harder as my characters got stronger
was really cool i'm currently trying to
get through city watch
so if any of you guys have any tips on
how to get past it then let me know
because
i need help we'll get together and i'll
send you my roster but make sure you
guys check out the link in the
description
or you can scan my qr code to download
disney heroes battle mode available in
the app store
and google play and hopefully you can
help me get past city watch
back into our video about the celestials
what we know is that before the marvel
multiverse was created
there existed a single omnipotent entity
known
as the first firmament now the first
firmament was quite literally the only
thing in all of existence unto a grew
lonely
and created two races of sentient beings
the aspirants who remained loyal to the
first firmament and did its bidding and
a rebellious group that desired to
create their own universes with life
forms that would adapt and evolve
and this is the group that would
eventually become known as the
celestials predictably the celestials
and the aspirants found it impossible to
remain in peaceful coexistence
and they went to war now it initially
looks as if the aspirants would be
victorious as they construct a weapon
known as the god killer
a 25 000 foot tall robot that they used
to kill
billions of celestials nearly wiping
them from existence
however with extinction seemingly
imminent the celestials were aided by
the emergence of a civil war among the
aspirants themselves which saw the god
killer stripped for parts for use in the
internal struggle now this proved to be
the turning point for the celestials who
detonate powerful weapons that nearly
wiped out the aspirants
as well as the first firmament itself
the result was that the first firmament
and the aspirants
left reality and a new reality was
formed from the pieces that remain
in the form of eternity now the
celestials remained in this new reality
which would come to be the first
multiverse and would take on the role of
creating life and aiding in its
evolution
throughout the multiverse choosing
planets suitable for sustaining life
and then seeding them with life and
returning periodically to monitor its
progress
so this is the origin of the celestials
and the purpose of this video is not to
recount the entire history of the
celestials we already have that it's
called the celestials explain you'll
find a link down in the description but
this video is designed to give you a
sense of how powerful they are
and that in and of itself is difficult
to do with
any level of precision for a couple of
different reasons one of these reasons
is the inconsistency from writer to
writer and how the celestials are
presented
and another is that lots of times when
the celestials show up we just kind of
see them being depicted as an
ominous threat without actually doing
anything so we have a limited number of
feats to go on but we're gonna do the
best we can so
one thing we know about the celestials
is that they are absolutely
massive standing two thousand feet tall
and weighing in
at 260 tons or 520 000 pounds so by that
alone
we know we're dealing with beings
capable of a great deal of destruction
but size alone
is not what it takes to make the
celestials a force to be reckoned with
after all
the villain apocalypse can grow to
thousand feet tall and he loses to the
x-men all the time
in terms of what powers they actually
possess the celestials are able to
manipulate
matter and energy and able to create
life for that reason they've been called
space gods by many in the marvel
universe now their power level
really is god-like as demonstrated
during an altercation with some of the
sky fathers of earth during the
celestial's third visit or
third host says it's called one of the
celestials irishman the judge
was attacked by odin zeus and vishnu
combining their energies these are
three of the most powerful deities in
marvel comics but their combined attack
did absolutely
nothing in fact the celestial threatened
to cut off each of the gods from their
divine realms and realizing that the
celestial could make good on his threat
these three deities submitted to arashim
who promises to return in a thousand
years
and judge the earth's worthiness to
exist now during the 1000 year period
odin orders the creation of the
destroyer armor which was thought to be
indestructible to thwart the judgment of
the celestials the destroyer however
proved to be the opposite of what odin
thought it was going to be when he was
no match for the celestials at all
another part of odin's plan was to grow
in size to equal that of the celestials
and use the odin sword which had been
imbued with nearly
all the souls of asgard and although he
was able to cut off the arm of one of
the celestials it grew back instantly
and this is just
one instance of the inconsistency i was
talking about earlier as
in this instance the odin sword cannot
permanently damage a celestial but in
another situation the apocalypse twins
killed a celestial with the asgardian
acts yarndrorn which shouldn't be as
powerful as the odin sword but like i
said
we have a lot of inconsistencies here
and that's just the reality we have to
deal with often
as comic readers and this seems to be an
outlier in how the celestials have been
depicted the only caveat i would give to
this
is that during rick remender's run on
uncanny avengers there was an
enchantment that made yarn bjorn capable
of killing celestials but it's kind of
weird that that enchantment could be put
on yarnbjorn but could not be put on the
odin sword that's that weird little
inconsistency that i'm talking about but
another thing we know
is that the celestials are responsible
for the creation of life throughout the
marvel multiverse now after visiting
earth nearly one million years ago they
modified the primitive inhabitants to
create the eternal and deviant races as
well as the race that would eventually
become humans
including modifying the dna of some
humans to include the potential to
develop superpowers it was also the
celestials who developed the scrolls
into a race capable of shape-shifting
through a series of genetic experiments
but just as they're able to create life
the celestial's potential for taking
life
is also immense for example after
judging one planet to be unworthy of
existence a celestial
literally destroys the entire planet and
everybody on it so they must've really
done something to piss that guy off
they're also capable of vast matter
manipulation as on another occasion the
celestial exotar transforms a planet
into a garden devoid of any evil
instead of destroying it after it's
judged and found wanting furthermore the
celestials are capable of creating
pocket universes
sustaining the life within them and then
also destroying them as one threatened
to destroy the hero's reborn universe
which was created by franklin richards
it was also the impending threat of a
celestial visiting earth that led to the
formation of the prehistoric avengers
team that was introduced in jason
aaron's current avengers run
and to get a sense of the power level
needed to stop a celestial
that team contained multiple people who
were all pretty much beyond omega level
which included odin
the phoenix force the star brand agamoto
the original sorcerer supreme the fact
that
so much power was needed to combat the
threat of a celestial
gives us an idea of how powerful they
are we also get some guidance as to
where celestial's rank on the power
hierarchy
within marvel comics when thanos states
that they're the same level as galactus
the stranger odin and
zeus but not as powerful as master order
and lord chaos however
this information is probably not
accurate anymore given that we know what
happened when zeus and odin tried to
attack a celestial it's hard to believe
they couldn't do any damage to him if
they're equal to him
we also know that even though they are
extremely powerful
the celestials are nowhere near as
powerful as the beyonders as we saw when
the beyonders eradicated them from
existence during jonathan hickman's time
runs out storyline although they have
since returned to comics but yeah this
should give you a really good idea of
how powerful the celestials are and i
don't think there's any argument that
they are
well beyond omega level i would love to
see somebody make this argument in the
comments section and for someone to
agree with it right because if you do
we will all laugh at you but with that
being said guys thanks for watching this
video
i love you guys to death and i will
catch you all later peace